في المقابل قال المصطفى بن المليح المنسق
والمقيم للامم المتحده ومنسق الشؤون
الانسانيه المؤقت في سوريا في مقابله مع
الجزيره قال انه من غير العادل القول لان
الامم المتحده لم تقم بواجبها في شمال
غربي سوريا وطالب بن مليح بتوفير الضمانات
الامنيه للدخول الى تلك المناطق
اما بالنسبه للشرقي فهذا يعني غير عادل
انه
الغربي
غير عادل ان يقال بان الامم المتحده او
المنظمات غير لم تقم بعملها او بمسؤوليتها
بالطريقه الصحيح لان حتى ندخل للعمل
الشمال الغربي لازم من موافقه من كل
الجهات عندنا الموافقه من الجهه الحكوميه
حتى الخط يعني الخط الفارق ما بين المناطق
اللي هي تدخل تحت سيطره
الحكومه السوريه والمناطق اللي فيها يعني
الجهات الاخرى
حتى ان نوصل للجهات الاخرى احنا نطلب
بموافقه وبالضوء الاخضر
بتوفير الامن والتغطيه
واضاف المصطفى بن مليح في المقابله مع
الجزيره انه لم يسمح بادخال اي قوافل
المساعدات في مناطق التماس في سوريا
نقاط
النظام لم يسمح باي قافله كان عندنا سماح
بقافلتين قبل قبل
الزلزال القافله رقم 11 والقافله رقم 12
وتم الغاء
القافلتين قبل يومين بسبب بدون اعطاء
اسباب كافيه والان نحن
توصلنا اوصل اليوم
يعني
بلانكيت يعني وصول بدون اي بدون اي شيء من
الحكومه ولكن حتى ندخل بعد يعني نفوت نقاط
التماس محتاجين بضمانات ضمانات امنيه
وكذلك ضوء اخضر